yes the number two player in the women's
event international master carissa you
have congratulations carissa on your
game you seem to come into the game with
like fire in your eyes with this the
sacrifice in the opening i'll go back uh
to
this point here where you play rookie
when you insist that you're not taking
back on c3 tell us about your
preparation
um well actually i wasn't expecting
queen b6 i was expecting bishop d7 on
move seven and then in that case the
sacrifice doesn't work as well
because if i play bishop d3 then uh the
black could just take on d4 and i play
like ricky one
oh sorry um
yeah like this line here here like i'm
kind of forced to take back on d4 and if
i tried to just leave the pawn layer
the whole idea of the line was like the
queen on b6 is a little misplaced
so
yeah so she surprised me a little with
queen v6 and uh i had this line
prepared a little bit like i looked at
it briefly but uh
i really wasn't expecting to play over
the board
so you get to this position where you're
both of you're arguing as we see here
nobody wants to take on c3 or you take
on d4 and finally she did play the move
f5 and it looks like you saw red uh
trying to keep the position
exciting and took on d4 finally to get
the action going
yeah i think like the whole idea for me
was that um she was like getting low on
time and it's just like objectively or
practically sorry a harder position to
play for her i think
so
that was kind of my main strategy
so i wasn't really looking to play like
the best moves but like
the moves that would be hardest for her
to deal with
very very practical way to play indeed
when she finally blundered like a
straight blunder it looks like bishop to
c6
you seem to think a little bit here
before playing bishop eight seven why
did you take so long
um
i know i was just like a little
hesitant i've been playing like a little
hesitantly lately because
i feel like i always don't really do so
well at this tournament so i'm trying to
be like a little more careful and stuff
and i mean at least when i had like an
hour so uh i had time to spare to really
sure did
drop the bomb with 94. now here i wasn't
too happy with your decision to go grab
the food with bishop to b6 why didn't
you just take on f6 since you if she
moved her queen you probably would have
done it anyway
yeah i mean
i don't really know honestly i was like
i just like didn't really consider that
she would just sacrifice her queen i was
expecting like queen bee to be forced
and i felt like
the addition of these two moves would be
better for me so like if i played knight
takes f6 now
and just get that extra nuance yeah so
then she sacrificed her queen by the way
i had these guys trying to win the
position against me after the queen
sacrifice
against the computer
and they weren't able to do it too
easily
but you did find the best move the
engine said rook to c1 and then she just
gave you the game instantly with knight
f5 she could have tried to fight on with
f5 herself
and make it a little bit more trouble
but then you were able to fly through so
you're at one and a half out of two how
are you feeling about your situation in
the tournament
i'm feeling good like i said i always
get kind of nervous for this tournament
so just kind of like trying to keep it
one game at a time sort of
i like the shirt by the way new york
represent
yes
uh we've got another new yorker
we've got a brooklyn night in the event
in arena crush she's the number one
ranked player in the tournament your
thoughts about her trying to get history
with nine wins and you're trying to stop
that
i mean i'll be happy for her if she does
make it but
hopefully
i can stop that
all right well good luck and we'll see
you tomorrow thank you quick question
for you carissa because just at the end
the very end you won in style so to
speak uh with this move queen c5 check
and uh
wins the game but for us old timers old
fogies we played the move rook g6 and we
don't even think about anything else
nothing cross else crosses our mind uh
did that move occur to you or queen c5
was your first move oh and you were
going for that all the way because rook
g6 we thought oh boy you know chris is
going to win the game for sure that way
yeah rich g6 was actually my first move
and then
i don't even know like i always i kind
of got my head a little bit i was like
oh my god what if i missed something and
i was like i feel like queen queen c5 is
safer just to get that pair rips off
queen c5 is safer okay
all right well very very nice finish uh
well done well done congratulations
carissa wow
more game
safer